this video is brought to you by
squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business check out squarespace
through the link in the description
below
more on them in just a bit
if you think of an authoritarian despot
you're probably picturing some decisive
charismatic and ruthless leaders someone
who addresses the masses in a commanding
booming voice basking in the glow of a
cult of personality today's protagonist
doesn't fill that description
not at all he remained a background
character a fence sitter for much of his
life and even when he rose to power he
never projected a menacing aura in fact
he wished to be remembered as the
smiling general but don't let an
unassuming smile fool you mr saharto was
a cunning and manipulative ruler capable
of swift violent action when times
called for it this is the story of how
ceharto rose to power in indonesia
during one of the worst massacres of the
20th century and how he maintained power
while bleeding the country dry
[Music]
sahada was born on the 8th of june 1921
in kamusu agyamuya near yogi yakata so
sorry about pronunciation this is in the
island of java modern day indonesia but
at the time it was part of the dutch
east indies he was named just sahato as
is common for many indonesians regarding
his family well there's not much we can
say with certainty according to the man
himself his parents were poor peasants
rumors speculated that he was the
legitimate son of a chinese businessman
while sources close to military
intelligence claimed that his parents
were of aristocratic stock more
realistically his father may have been a
village irrigation official so not a
poor peasant but
certainly not an aristocrat either
regardless of his origins sardo's family
could certainly not splash the cash in
fact he once had to drop out of school
because he couldn't afford the required
uniform the young sahato had more
clothing malfunctions after graduating
high school he had secured a job as a
bank clerk but after his suit got torn
in a bicycle accident he had to quit the
job there was one employer which could
provide the right attire at any time
though the military as a means to
elevate his social standing sahato
joined the dutch colonial forces when
the imperial japanese navy invaded
indonesia in 1942 the young soldier
promptly switched uniforms he joined a
japanese-sponsored militia where he
trained as an officer sure the japanese
were invaders but they were not as hated
as the retreating dutch colonial
overlords in fact when the japanese
surrendered in august 1945 zahaso joined
the newly formed indonesian army
fighting for independence against the
returning dutch occupation forces this
new force was led by generals ahmed
sakhano and muhammad hatha inspired by
nationalist and anti-colonialist
ideology the two officers also relied on
the support of communist and islamic
factions the fragile balance between
these three forces nationalism communism
religion would be a staple of indonesian
politics for many years to come
[Music]
all right so let's get back to the fight
for independence dutch forces had landed
in sumatra and java making considerable
territorial gains the indonesian forces
were armed with equipment left over by
the japanese but the lack of heavy
weaponry meant that they had to resort
to guerrilla tactics the uniformed army
also lacked trained officers which may
explain why sahato was promoted to the
rank of lieutenant colonel at the young
age of just 24 and he was in for more
promotions in 1948 sahara was given
command of a brigade stationed around
yogyakarta he had the chance to prove
his worth on the 19th of december when
dutch forces attacked by surprise well
he couldn't really prove much as his
entire brigade happened to be outside of
the city the dutch captured yogyakarta
without firing a shot a serious setback
for the anti-colonial forces in march of
1949 sahato led a counter-attack to
retake the lost positions this action
was later immortalized in the epic 979
film janukooning but in reality there
wasn't really much to be epic about the
attack was repulsed after six hours and
it didn't really do much damage to the
enemy nonetheless the struggle for
freedom had continued with more success
elsewhere by 1949 the anti-guerrilla
campaign was proving too costly to the
dutch government moreover the
international community didn't support
this colonial cause devastated by the
german occupation in world war ii the
netherlands badly needed financial aid
from the u.s which came with a condition
leave indonesia alone in december of
1949 the republic of indonesia was
granted independence with socano as
president and hatta as prime minister
saharto had received a further promotion
to colonel over the following years he
remained in the background as an
unremarkable figure which nonetheless
rose steadily through the ranks in 1959
he was appointed major general in
command of the central java military
district this appointment was
short-lived though as his superiors
removed him on allegations of accepting
bribes and yet he managed to regain his
position shortly afterwards and continue
on with his career by 1963 the general
had become head of the army strategic
command a rapid reaction force based in
the capital city of jakarta tasked with
responding to national emergencies it
was a prestigious posting but sahato
could do a bit better and he did two
years later the ambitious officer
reported directly to general yani the
commander-in-chief of the army whenever
daddy was traveling ill or otherwise
incapacitated sahato would take his role
in the interim it all seemed set for
sahato to take over during an emergency
one that would very soon come along
but before we get there let me give you
some background on how tensions were
building in the country in 1959
president secano implemented an
authoritarian system called guided
democracy which allowed him to exert
large influence over the parliament his
agenda during guided democracy was based
on three points first a shift towards
socialist and populist reforms a
continuation of the anti-dutch
revolution second a strong
anti-colonialist stance in foreign
affairs matters third economic
self-reliance and nationalization of
foreign assets however poor
implementation of agricultural reforms
and economic policies resulted in low
production levels compared with
inflation this in turn contributed to
social unrest and the growing popularity
of the pki the indonesian communist
party by 1965 the pki claimed to have
3.5 million members it could also rely
on 23.5 million members in affiliated
organizations trade unions and youth
movements for example this made the pki
the largest communist party outside of
the ussr and china while many officers
supported the pki the army saw its
growing popularity with suspicion of
fearing a communist takeover of the
country they started to meet with
religious leaders forging a preemptive
alliance amidst the backroom maneuvering
zahato sat firmly on the fence then in
the latter half of 1965 rumors reached
socano's inner circle that a group of
leftist officers were planning a coup in
the early hours of october the first
1965 things came to a head an armed
group called the 30th of a september
movement kidnapped six of the highest
ranking generals and one lieutenant the
seven officers were then executed and
dumped into a well in east jakarta this
violent action caused the death of an
eighth innocent victim the six-year-old
daughter of general association the
movement's leader lieutenant colonel and
tung of the presidential guard ordered
the seizure of the state broadcasting
service from there the insurgents
proclaimed a new revolutionary
government but
who was behind this coup according to
professor john russa from the university
of british columbia some top leaders of
the pki had played a role in the plot
but most party cardras were unaware of
the plans the pki's youth organization
had also been trained for military
action but were left on standby without
orders and they had no idea that they
would go after the army rusa also noted
how two of the conspirators were good
friends of sahato one of them colonel
latif later declared in court that
zahato was aware of their plot to kill
the officers all in all at least part of
the pki was behind the plot tarto was
aware of it but he did nothing to
prevent it it was only a few hours after
the assassinations that zahato finally
decided to jump off his fence and take
advantage of his emergency powers just
before we get into the rest of today's
video a word from today's sponsor
squarespace look it's a new year so
whatever that new thing you're thinking
about doing maybe it's a resolution of
some kind maybe you're resoluting is
that a word to start a new website well
do it with squarespace with squarespace
the world is yours it's the platform to
use when you've got a new web project
you want to do if you want to get in and
out quick use one of their beautiful
templates they're very easy you pick one
it's beautiful then your website is
almost good to go maybe you've got to
change the text and a few things around
otherwise it just looks like the
template but it's very easy or maybe
more of a hands-on person like templates
are for me those look great but i've got
design skills well great news
squarespace is heavily customizable so
you can make it look however you want it
to look and then there are no updates no
patches no technical nonsense to worry
about and once you've done setting up
your website there's tons of extra
features so that it can thrive email
complaints patronage portals social
integrations member only areas analytics
commercial options 24 7 customer support
that's a lot of things in fact seven
things they're all in one easy place
called squarespace so when you're ready
to get started on the next project of
yours big or small if it involves a
website do it with squarespace go to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch your new
site go to squarespace.com forward slash
biographics and you'll save 10 of your
first purchase of a website or a domain
and back to today's video
one of the murdered officers was general
yanni with him gone zahato was formally
in command of the army he quickly
stepped into the phrase swiftly
repressing the 30th of september
movement and controlling the narrative
of the events he and other top officers
inflamed public opinion against the pki
squarely blaming the assassinations and
the attempted coup on the entire
organization it supporters and according
to documents declassified by the us
government the cia supported zohato and
his propaganda efforts by supplying
communications equipment but despite the
propaganda and pressure from the
generals socano refused to ban the pki
this was all the motivation that zahato
needed to initiate a violent purge
against the party his first action was
to dispatch the rp kad the paratrooper
commando units to central java and bali
here communist party leaders party
members or just suspected sympathizers
were rounded up and slayed on mass the
massacres soon spread throughout the
entire archipelago often the killings
were perpetrated directly by the regular
armed forces they were mostly busy and
purging those units who had sided with
kpi the presidential guard two divisions
in central java and much of the air
force when it came to civilians the
military preferred to arm and train
militia units and allow the militias to
carry out the dirty work these militias
were recruited mainly amongst the ansar
the youth wing of the islamic national
organization
llama or nu the enu was already
anti-communist but to further motivate
them army officers circulated the news
that pkl activists held hit lists of
islamic leaders from the perspective of
the ansar it was a case of kill or be
killed the answer was not alone the army
mobilized now members of the catholic
and nationalist parties most of these
militias operated in rural areas an
armed band would target a village
suspected of supporting the pki they
would surround it seize party members
and sympathizers and detain them in
temporary detention centers where
prisoners were tortured and interrogated
what happened next is best described by
a chilling declassified cable sent by
edwardi masters political affairs
councillor at the u.s embassy in jakarta
on the 30th of november 965 he wrote
repression of the phi continued with the
main problem that's of what to feed and
where to house the prisoners many
provinces appear to be successfully
meeting the problem by executing their
pki prisoners or killing them before
they are captured prisoners were marched
into the forests for the final act they
were shot stabbed beaten to death and
their bodies dumped into mass graves in
many cases bodies were thrown into
rivers or left to rot in the streets to
further terrorize local populations
militias took to mutilating corpses and
leaving their heads and genitals in full
view
the purges continued into 1966 while no
documents have proven that zahato
directly ordered the killings he was at
the top of the chain of command and
directed the actions of the paratroopers
and the training of the militias
professor russa guesses that zahato must
have at least approved of the massacres
according to professor brad simpson
university of connecticut the
extermination of the pki propelled his
career even further socano far from
doing anything concrete to stop the
bloodshed confirmed sahato's status as
commander-in-chief and on the 11th of
march 1966 the president signed the
supersema decree which bestowed sahato
with full powers to guarantee security
calm and stability in the country the
general interpreted this decree to his
advantage arresting 15 ministers and
dismissing the rest of the cabinet by
march 12th zahato was the de facto head
of the indonesian government with cicada
still in place as nominal president in
march 1967 the people's consultive
assembly appointed sahato acting
president the consolation of his power
became complete exactly one year later
in march of 1968 the assembly elected
zahato was president with full powers
for the first of many five-year terms
the low-profile general until now a
power in the shadows had risen to full
power sailing unscathed amidst a tempest
bloodshed he and a circle of officers
had instigated it's still difficult to
estimate the toll that this purge
exacted on the indonesian people due to
a lack of reliable records estimates of
mass murders range from a hundred
thousand to two million victims
historian robert krib suggests that half
a million dead could be an accurate
figure in addition to those slain almost
three-quarters of a million indonesians
were imprisoned with sentences ranging
from one to thirty years many
high-ranking members of the pki were
sentenced to death while most members
were sentenced to hard labor members of
the gewani the movement of conscious
indonesian women were also subjected to
sexual abuse and rape while in jail
in march 1966 sahato began implementing
a series of policies which he called oda
bahru or new order the first policy
shift was to deeper to size indonesian
society sahato created a system by which
citizens were organized in hundreds of
functional groups one for peasants one
for civil servants one for business
owners and so on the tactic was designed
to prevent the formation of trade unions
and to ensure capillary control of the
population these groups were coordinated
by the organization galongankaya or
golkar for short which became the
predominant political party sato also
ensured that the military fulfilled a
dual function both as a defense
organization and as a political force
becoming the actual rulers of the
country then sahato restored ties with
the west and put an end to a costly
military confrontation with malaysia
initiated by socano in january of 1963.
finally sarato realized that a stable
rule required improving living standards
for indonesians to boost the economy he
did a u-turn on socano's policies no
more talk of self-reliance on
nationalization the new ruler welcomed
with open arms foreign investments
especially in the oil sector and if
ungrateful oil workers dared to form
unions and kick up a stink no problem
sarto's soldiers would intervene to
preserve a harmonious working
environment another pillar of sahato's
stability was the massive growth of the
public sector by the early 1970s about
1.5 million indonesians were employed by
the state the number tripled over the
next three decades civil servants not
only enjoyed a steady salary they were
also provided a chance to boost revenue
with some bribery on the side this
system guaranteed zahadu and golkara a
steady base of voters at every election
in the late 1970s sahato also sought to
build a more benevolent image for
himself to the outside world who largely
saw him as a despot he opened the
country to foreign investment and had to
bow to certain international pressure at
least partially i wanted him to dial
down the authoritarianism you know just
a tad and he did this he released tens
of thousands of political prisoners but
this is not to say that the smiling
general renounced his old ways the army
was always ready to react with swift
brutality against real or perceived
threats especially against those
movements who threatened the integrity
of the nation for example the local
population in papua was kept in a state
of constant violent counter-insurgency
by the armed forces this happened all
the way from the late 60s to 1998. yet
during the late 1960s and early 1970s
indonesia under sahato's new order
appeared like a success story
[Music]
sato's rule was definitely authoritarian
yet he was clever enough to always
operate within constitutional boundaries
the new president had successfully
restored order to the country although
we may argue that he and his faction
were largely responsible for
the initial state of disorder indonesia
had also become a key player in the game
of chess that was the cold war before
socano could drift toward the communist
bloc zahato had yanked the country in
the opposite direction under his
authority jakarta became one of the
founding members of the association of
southeast asian nations or asian the
equivalent of nato for the region but
his greatest achievement was to restore
economic growth under the new order
every year the local economy grew 6.6 on
average living standards improved in
general although the public sector the
military and urban elites benefited more
than other classes this growth was
driven by foreign investments and
especially by the mass export of
indonesia's vast natural resources
mainly oil and timber revenues from
these sales were reinvested by the
government into the expansion of urban
and suburban areas as well as literacy
programs and family planning initiatives
but this expansion had a rotten core
sahato and his cabinet failed to
reinvest into the development of state
infrastructure and into the local
manufacturing sector worse than that
much of the income from oil and timber
disappeared into the deep pockets of
sahato his allies and his six children
an example of this mismanagement is the
state-owned oil company pertamina
compared to the malaysian equivalent
patronus this company had access to much
larger oil reserves and yet it
consistently unperformed compared to its
neighbor in theory pertamina could have
been a cash cow in practice it was only
milked by sahara's family
[Music]
now cracks in the international facade
began to form in the mid-1970s most
population was pretty fed up with the
corruption and collusion and the
nepotism that was rampant in sahato's
circle students were especially
disillusioned with the inflow of foreign
investments and how they were
essentially just funneled straight into
sahato's wallet on january the 15th of
1974 japanese prime minister kakoe
tanaka was in jakarta for an official
visit it was the perfect occasion for
thousands of students to stage massive
protests and thus embarrass the
authoritarian leader the protests
degenerated into 12 hours of riots with
fires blazing throughout jakarta these
became known as the malari rods sato
reacted with a signature mix of the
carrot and the stick first he had 12
newspapers shut down and its journalists
imprisoned without a draw the remaining
publications began applying a form of
self-censorship which effectively curbed
any dissenting voice but then he
complied with some of the protesters
requests the government enacted
restrictive measures on foreign
investments favoring the development of
local businesses the next crisis took
place in november of 1975. the east now
for the island of timur until then a
portuguese colony declared independence
the independent east timor was led by
the left-leaning party teflon and sahato
could not tolerate a communist threat on
its borders in december the army invaded
annexing east timor as the 27th province
of indonesia the international community
protested the invasion and the u.n did
not recognize the annexation but in
practical terms joha's troops were free
to garrison the territory and even
freyja to carry out a brutal campaign of
repression which claimed up to 200 000
lives
[Music]
international star sean again briefly in
the following decade in 1985 he traveled
to rome for an award ceremony at the
headquarters for the food and
agricultural organization the fao he was
celebrated for having raised rice
production in indonesia the country was
now self-sufficient in that respect and
didn't need to import rice any longer
but that was a temporary triumph sure
crops have been growing from 1977 to
1982 but they started to decline soon
afterward since then the government had
in fact encouraged the conversion of
rice paddies into suburban development
projects by the early 1990s indonesians
were back to importing large shipments
of rice mismanagement and corruption had
created a bit of a paradoxical situation
indonesia had all the fertile land and
agricultural labor required to feed its
growing population in theory in practice
arable land was destined for other
purposes and hundreds of thousands of
farmers were forced to migrate seeking
employment in neighboring countries the
regime had thus alienated any remnant of
support by the rural masses next in line
were the backbone of gold car supporters
middle class civil servants and small
business owners until then the mirage of
continued growth had kept them at bay
and silenced any voice rising against
the bad habit of pocketing the kickbacks
in 1997 however indonesia became one of
the main victims of currency crisis
which devastated the economies of
southeast asia the country faced every
economist's worst nightmare stagflation
a lethal mix of recession and soaring
inflation zahato resisted demands for
structural reforms while living
standards rapidly collapsed nationwide a
mass movement for reformacy or
institutional reform took to the streets
anti-government demonstrations broke out
in jakarta and other cities in may of
1998. confronted by the security forces
protests escalated into violent riots
which claimed more than a thousand
victims by now the once smiling general
realized that he lacked the political
and military backing to intensify the
crackdown on may 21 of 1998 zahato saw
the writing on the wall and thought it
was best to resign his deputy baka
rodinius of habibi became indonesia's
third president sato left power with an
apology to the nation i'm sorry for my
mistakes
well i mean thanks but maybe it's not
enough in fact the new cabinet demanded
more than an apology in 2000 the
government filed embezzlement charges
against him sato was accused of
misappropriating the equivalent of more
than 600 million us dollars but the
former despot was in ill health and the
charges were dropped in 2007 the un and
the world bank estimated the true extent
of his pilfering value was estimated
between 15 and 35 billion american
dollars in 2007 time magazine picked up
the story reporting that sahara and his
family had stolen 15 billion the
magazine was sued for defamation a court
case which zahato won in november of
that year in the meantime the indonesian
government tried again to sue him for
embezzlement and in december they
announced an investigation into six
cases of human rights abuse one of them
was about the massacres of
1965-66 but sato would never face trial
on the 4th of january 2008 the former
general and president was hospitalized
due to complications of renal failure
among many other ailments his health
quickly worsened due to internal
bleeding and sepsis sarto was declared
dead on the 27th of january but then
president yudhoyono asked indonesians to
respect one of their top countrymen just
two months earlier that top countryman
had laughed off his allegations it's all
empty talk let them accuse me the fact
is i have never committed corruption
so i really hope you found today's video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe and as always
thank you for watching
[Music]